the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so recall that yesterday we so know two
days ago we learned about the curl of a
vector field in space okay and we said
the curl of F is defined by taking a
cross product between the symbol Dell
and the vector F so concretely the way
we would compute this would be by
putting the components of F into this
determinant and expanding and then
getting a vector with components Y minus
QZ PZ minus R X and QX minus py so I
think I also try to explain very quickly
what's the significance of a curl just
to tell you again very quickly basically
curl measures if you take if you imagine
that your vector field measures the
velocity in some fluid then the curl
measures how much rotation is taking
place in that fluid so measures the
rotation part is about rotation part of
a velocity field
so more precisely the direction
corresponds to the axis of rotation and
the magnitude corresponds to twice the
angular velocity
okay so well I mean just to give you a
quick a few quick examples if I take a
constant vector field you know so
everything translates at the same speed
well then obviously when you take the
partial derivatives you'll just get a
bunch of zeroes so the curl will be zero
if you take a vector field that
stretches things let's say for example
going to stretch things along the x axis
so that would be a vector field that
goes parallel to the X direction but
maybe you know say x times I so that
when you're in front of a plane of a
blackboard you're moving forward when
you're behind you're moving backwards
things are getting expanded in the X
direction well if you compute the curl
well you can check each of these terms
is again going to be zero there's no
curl this is not what curl measures I
mean actually what measures expansion
stretching is actually divergence you
take the divergence of this field well
you'll get 1 plus 0 plus 0 looks like it
will be 1 so in case you don't remember
I mean divergence precisely measures
this stretching effect in your field and
in the other hand on the other hand if
you take something that corresponds to
say rotation about the z axis at unit
angular velocity so that means we will
be moving in circles around the z axis
so one way to write down this field
let's see so with Z component is 0
because it's moving everything is moving
horizontally and in the x and y
directions
look at it from above well it's just
going to be our good old friend the
vector field that rotates everything as
unit speed and we've seen the formula
for this one many times the first
component is minus y the second one is X
okay now if you compute the curl of this
guy you'll get 0 0 2 or 2 K and so K is
the axis of rotation 2 is twice V
angular velocity and now of course you
can imagine much more complicated
motions where you'll have you know for
example if you look at the charge paper
very carefully then you'll see that the
water is flowing generally speaking
towards the ocean but at the same time
there are actually a few you know
Eddie's in there and with what else
warning and those are the places where
there is actually curl in the flow yes I
don't know how to turn out the lights a
bit but I'm sure there is a way does
this do it
is it working okay you're welcome
okay hopefully it's easier to see now so
okay so that was about curl now what
does curl you know what would do why do
we care about curl besides this
motivation of understanding motions well
so one place where it comes up is when
we try to understand whether a vector
field is conservative remember we've
seen that a vector field is conservative
if and only if its curl is zero so
that's the situation in which we are
allowed to try to look for a potential
function and then use the fundamental
theorem but another place where this
comes up if you remember what we did in
the plane curl also came up when we try
to convert line integrals into double
integrals that was greens theorem so
turns out we can do the same thing in
space and that's called Stokes theorem
okay so what does Stokes theorem say it
says that the work done by a vector
field along a closed curve can be
replaced by a double integral of curl F
let me write it using the Dell notation
if you prefer that's curl F dot NDS on a
suitably chosen surface so that's a very
strange kind of statement but actually
it's not much more strange than things
we've seen before so I should clarify
what this means so C has to be a closed
curve in space and s can be any surface
bounded base
okay so for example what Stokes theorem
tells me is that let's say that I have
to compute some line integral on maybe
say the unit circle in the XY plane okay
of course I can set up the line integral
directly and compute it by setting you
know x equals cosine T y equals sine T Z
equals zero but maybe sometimes I don't
want to do that because my vector field
is really complicated and instead I will
want to reduce things to a surface
integral now I know that you guys are
not necessarily fond of computing flux
of vector fields for surfaces so maybe
you don't really see the point but
sometimes it's useful sometimes it's
also useful backwards because actually
you have a surface integral that you'd
like to turn into a line integral so
what Stokes theorem says is that you
know if I I can choose my favorite
surface whose boundary is this circle so
I could choose for example have sphere
if I want or I can choose let's call
that s1 or I can choose I don't know a
pointy thing as to I can choose you know
probably the most logical winner she
would be just to choose a disk in the XY
plane that would probably be the easiest
one to set up for calculating flux but
anyway what Stokes theorem tells me is I
can choose any of these surfaces
whichever one I want and they can
compute the flux of curl F for this
surface so curl F is a new vector field
right when you have this formula that
gives you a vector field you compute its
flux for your favorite surface and you
should get the same thing as if you had
done the line integral for F ok that's
the statement
now there's a catch here what's the
catch well the catch is we have to
figure out what conventions to use
because remember when we have a surface
there's two possible orientations so we
have to decide which way we will count
reflects positively which we will count
flux negatively and if we make B if we
change our choice then of course the
flux will become the opposite well
similarly to define the work I need to
choose which way I'm going to hang my
curve if I change which way I go around
the curve then my work will become the
opposite so what happens is I have to
orient the curve C and the surface s in
compatible ways so we have to figure out
what's the rule for how the orientation
of s and that of C relate to each other
okay so what about orientation well we
need the orientations of C and s to be
compatible and they have to explain to
you what the hole is so the hole is let
me show you a picture
so the whole is if I walk along C with s
to my left then the normal vector is
pointing up for me let me write that if
I walk along c I should say in the
positive direction in the direction that
I've chosen to I and C with s to my left
then n is pointing up for me okay so
here it's the example if I'm walking on
this curve looks like the surface is to
my left and so the normal vector is
going towards you know what's up for me
any questions about that
yeah I see some people using the right
hands there's also height Hannibal which
I'm going to say in just a few moments
that's another way to remember this but
okay so before I tell you about the
right hand roll version let me just
clarify something so let's save it and
actually you know not happy with this
orientation of see and I want to orient
make up see going clockwise on the
picture so we other orientation then if
I walk on it this way the surface would
be to my right so you can remember if it
helps you that if a service is to your
right when the normal vector will go
down we have a way to think about it
this whole is enough because if you're
walking clockwise where you can change
that to counterclockwise just by walking
upside down okay so this guy is walking
clockwise on C and well for him if you
look carefully at the picture for him
the surface is actually to his left
right when you flip upside down
yeah it's kind of confusing but anyway I
just want point out okay so maybe it's
easier if you actually rotate the entire
picture and now it's getting actually
really confusing because well so he's
walking upside up with actually the
surfaces to his left I mean where he is
here is actually at the front and this
is the back but that's kind of hard to
see so anyway whichever method will work
best for you
perhaps it's easiest to first do it with
the other orientation this one and then
this side that you know if you want the
opposite one then you'll just flip
everything okay now what's the other way
of remembering this with the right hand
rules with the right hand rule so first
of all take your right hand not your
left hand even if your right hand is
actually using you know a band or
something like that in your right hand
to do this and let's take your fingers
in order so first your thumb let's make
your thumb go along the object that has
only one dimension in there that's the
curve okay
so put your finger well let's look at
the top picture out there okay so I want
my thumb to go along the curve so that's
kind of towards the height then I want
to make my index finger points towards
the surface so towards the surface I'm
in towards the interior of the surface
from the curve right when I'm in the
curve I'm on the boundary of the surface
so there's a direction along the surface
that's the curve and the other one is
pointing into the surface so that one
would be pointing kind of to the back
slightly up maybe okay so like that and
now your middle finger is going to point
in the direction of a normal vector
let's up at least if you have the same
kind of right hand as I do
okay so the other way of doing it is
using the right hand rule from along C
positively the index finger towards the
interior of s sorry I shouldn't say
Intel maybe I should say tangent to s
towards the interior of this so what I
mean by that is really the part of s
that's not its boundary okay so the rest
of the surface then the middle finger
points parallel to n okay
so let's practice let's say that I give
you this curve bounding this surface
which way do you think the normal vector
will be going up yes everyone's voting
up okay imagine what I'm walking around
see Isis to my left normal vector points
up imagine that you put your thumb along
see your middle finger towards s your
index sorry your index towards s then
your middle finger points up very good
so and points up okay another one
okay it's interesting to watch you guys
I think mostly it's going up so the
correct answer is it goes up and into
the cone okay so how do we see that so
well one way to think about it is
imagine that you are walking on sea on
the rim of this cone so you have two
options imagine that you're walking it's
kind of inside or imaginary or walking
kind of outside if you're walking
outside then s is - you're right within
sound good so let's say instead that
you're walking on the inside of a cone
following the boundary well then the
surface is to your left and so the
normal vector will be up for you which
means it will be pointing slightly up
and into the cone okay another way to
think about it to the right-hand hole
from this way index going kind of down
because the surface goes down and a bit
to the back and then the normal vector
points opened in yet another way if you
deform continuously your surface then
the conventions will not change see this
is kind of topology in a way you can
deform things nothing will change so
what if we somehow you know flatten our
cone push it a bit up so that it becomes
completely flat then you know if you had
a flat disc with the curve going
counterclockwise the normal vector would
go up so now take your disk with its
normal vector sticking up if you want
paint the top face you know a different
color so that you remember that was the
side with a normal vector and then push
it back down to the cone you'll see that
the painted face the one with a normal
vector on that side is the one that's
inside and up okay does that make sense
anyway I think you have just to you know
play with these examples for long enough
and get it okay last one
let's say that I have a cylinder so now
this guy has actually two boundary
curves C and C Prime and let's say I
want to orient my cylinder so that the
normal vector sticks out how should I
choose the orientation of my curves okay
so let's start with let's say with a
bottom one
would the bottom one be going clockwise
or counterclockwise yeah most people
seem to say counterclockwise and I agree
with that okay so let me write that down
I claim C prime should go
counterclockwise one way to think about
it actually heads pretty easy imagine
that you're walking on the outside of
the cylinder along C prime if you want
to walk along C prime so that the
cylinder is to your left that means you
have to actually go counterclockwise
around it the other way is use your
right hand thumb so say when you want
the front of C prime your thumb points
to the right your index points up
because that's where the surface is and
then your middle finger will point out
okay what about C
well see I claim we should be doing
clockwise okay I mean think about just
walking again on the surface of the
cylinder along see if you walk clockwise
you will see that the surface is to your
left or use right Hannibal okay so now
if a problem gives you neither of the
orientation of a curve nor that of the
surface then it's up to you to make to
make them up but you have to make them
up in a consistent way you can't choose
them both at random okay all right so
now we are all set to try to use Stokes
theorem
so well let me do an example first the
first example that I will do is actually
a comparison Stokes versus green so I
want to show you how greens theorem for
work that we saw in the plane that also
involved work and curl and so on is
actually a special case of this okay so
let's say that we'll look at the special
case where our curve C is actually a
curve in the xy-plane
and let's make it go counterclockwise in
the xy-plane because that's what we did
for greens theorem
okay now let's choose a surface bounded
by this curve well as I say they could
make up any crazy surface that comes to
my mind but if I want to relate to 2d
stuff I should probably stay in the XY
plane so I'm just going to take my
surface to be the piece of the XY plane
that's inside my curve okay so let's say
s is going to be a portion of xy-plane
bounded by a curve C and the curve C
goes counterclockwise
well then I should look at the line
integral so the work along see of my
favorite vector field FDR so that will
be the line integral of pdx plus qdy I
guess if I call my components so
components of my field P Q and R it will
be pdx plus qdy plus rdz but i don't
have an easy here DZ is 0 on on C ok so
if I evaluate the line integral I don't
have any term involving DZ Z is 0 now
let's see what Stokes says Stokes says
instead I can compute the flux OS of
curl F but now what's the normal vector
to nice office well it's going to be
either K or negative K I just have to
figure out which one it is well if you
followed what we've done there you know
that the normal vector compatible with
this choice for the curve C is the one
that points up okay so my normal vector
is just going to be K hat
okay so I'm going to replace my normal
vector by K hat so that means actually I
will be integrating curl dot K that
means I'm integrating the Z component of
curl so let's look at curl F dot K
that's the Z component of curl F and
what's the component what's the Z
component of curl well I convenient I
still have values up there it's Q sub X
minus P sub y okay so my double integral
becomes double integral of Q sub X minus
P sub y what about DS well I'm in a
piece of the XY plane so DS is just DX
dy or your favorite combination that
does the same thing so now see if you
look at this equality integral of pdx
plus qdy along a closed curve equals
double integral of QX minus py DX dy but
exactly the statement of greens theorem
right I mean except at that time we call
things m and n but really that shouldn't
matter okay so this tells you
but in fact greens theorem is just a
special case of Stokes in the xy-plane
okay now another small remark I want to
make by the way before I forget so you
might think that you know this these
rules that we've made up about
compatibility of orientations they are
completely arbitrary
well they're arbitrary in the same way
as our convention for which guy we call
curl is arbitrary we chose to make the
curl be this thing and not you know the
opposite which would have been quite
image as just as sensible and ultimately
that comes from our choice of making the
cross-product be what it is rather than
the opposite so ultimately it all comes
from our preference for right-handed
coordinate systems you know if we had
been on the planet with left-handed
coordinate systems then actually our
conventions would be all the other way
around but they are this way okay
any other questions
yes
so the surface as you use it Stokes
theorem is usually not going to be
closed because it's boundary needs to be
the curve C so if you had a closed
surface you know you wouldn't know where
to put your curve I mean of course you
could make a tiny hole in it and get a
tiny curve so actually what that would
say and we're going to see more about
that so not very important right now but
what we would see is that for a closed
surface we would end up getting 0 for
the flux and that's actually because
divergence of curl is 0 but I'm getting
ahead of myself so we're going to see
that probably tomorrow in more detail
yes it's a very question to know Stokes
fear and only works if you can make
sense of this so that means if you you
need your vector field to be continuous
and differentiable everywhere on the
surface s ok so now why is that relevant
well say that your vector field was not
defined at the origin and say that you
want it to do you know the example that
I had first with the unit circle in the
XY plane
so normally the most sensible choice of
surface to apply Stokes theorem to would
be just the flat disk in the XY plane
but the weather assumes that your vector
field is well-defined there if your
vector field is not defined at the
origin but defined everywhere else you
can use this guy but maybe you can still
use silver half sphere for example or
you could use you know a piece of
cylinder plus a flat top or whatever you
want but not passing for the origin so
you could still use Stokes but you'd
have to be careful about which surface
you choose now if instead your vector
field is not defined anywhere on the z
axis then you're out of luck because
there's no way to find a surface bounded
by this unit circle without crossing the
z axis somewhere so then you wouldn't be
able to use Stokes theorem at all or at
least not directly
yeah so the implicit thing and I should
say okay so maybe I should write it and
I've defined and differentiable
everywhere on this but we don't care
about what happens outside of this it's
really only on the surface that we
needed to be okay I mean again 99% of
the vector fields that we see in this
class are defined everywhere so that's
not a very you know it's not a an urgent
concern but still okay should we move on
yes I have a yes okay so let me explain
to you quickly why Stokes is for this
tool so how do we prove a theorem like
that well the strategy I mean there's
other ways but the least painful
strategy at this point is to observe
that we already know special case of
Stokes theorem namely we know the case
where the curve is actually in the XY
plane and the surface is a flat piece of
the XY plane because that's green leafy
greens theorem which we buffer to prove
a while ago so first thing is we know we
know it for C and s in the XY plane
now what if C and s were saying the Y Z
plane in the XY plane well then you know
it wouldn't quite be the same picture
because the normal vector would be I hat
instead of K hat and they would be
having different notations and you know
it would be integrating with y&z but you
see that it would become again exactly
the same formula so we'd know it for any
of the coordinate planes in fact I claim
we know it for absolutely any plane and
the reason for that is sure you know
when we write it in coordinates when we
write you know that this line integral
is integral of
pdx plus qdy plus rdz or when we write
that the curl is given by this formula
we use the XYZ coordinate system but
there's something I haven't quite told
you about which is if I switch to any of
a right-handed coordinate system so I do
some sort of rotation of my space
coordinates then somehow the line
integral the flux integral the notion of
curl make sense independently of
coordinates and the reason is that we
all have geometric interpretations for
example when I think of this as the work
done by a force well the first doesn't
care whether it's being put in XYZ
coordinates this way or that way it
still does the same work because it's
the same force and when I say that the
curl measures the rotation in a motion
well that doesn't depend on which
coordinates you use and same for the
interpretation of flux so in fact if I
rotated my coordinates to fit with any
other plane I could still do the same
things so what I'm trying to say is in
fact if C and s are in any plane then we
can still claim that it reduces to
Green's theorem just it will be greens
theorem not in Xyz coordinate but in
some funny rotated coordinate systems so
what I'm using is that work flux and
curl make sense independently of
coordinates
now I mean this has to stop somewhere I
can start claiming that I can you know
somehow bend my coordinates to claim
that any surface is flat that doesn't
really work but what I can say is if I
have any surface I can cut it into tiny
pieces and these tiny pieces are
basically flat so that's basically the
idea of a probe I'm going to decompose
my surface into very small flat pieces
so given any s we are just going to
decompose it into tiny almost flat
pieces so you know for example if I have
my surface like this what I will do is I
will just you know cut it into tiles I
mean a good example of that is you know
if you look at those geodesic things so
if you look like you know at a soccer
ball for example it's made of all of
these you know hexagons and pentagons
and well actually they're not quite flat
and usual but you could make them flat
and it would still look pretty much like
a sphere so anyway you're going to you
know cut your surface into lots of tiny
pieces and then you can use Stokes
theorem on each small piece what it says
on each small flat piece that's where my
chalk is it says that the line integral
along say for example this curve is
equal to the flux of the curl for this
tiny piece of surface and now I'll add
all of these terms together if I add all
of the small contributions to flux I get
the total flux what if I add all of the
small line
integrals well I get lots of extra junk
because I never asked to compute the
line integral along this but this guy
will come in twice when I do this little
plate and when I do that little plate
with opposite orientations so when I sum
all of the little line integrals
together all of the inner things cancel
out and the only ones that I go for only
ones are those that are at the outermost
edges so when I sum all of my works
together
I will get the work done just along the
outer boundary see okay so some of work
around each little piece is just
actually to work along see the outer
curve and the sum of the flux for each
piece is going to give the flux for s so
from Stokes theorem for flat surfaces I
can get it for any surface I'm cheating
a little bit because you'd actually have
to check carefully that this
approximation where you flatten the
little pieces that are almost flat is
valid but trust me it actually works
okay
so without question but I okay so let's
do an actual example I mean I say the
example but you know that was more like
getting us ready for the proof so
probably that doesn't count as an actual
example I should probably keep these
statements for now so I'm not going to
erase this side
okay so it's not an example let's try to
find the work of a vector field Zi plus
XJ plus YK around the unit circle in the
XY plane counterclockwise so the picture
is conveniently already there
so just as a quick review let's see how
we do that directly if we do that
directly I have to find the integral
along c of so f dot d R becomes Z DX
plus X dy plus y DZ but now we actually
know that on the on the circle well Z is
zero and we can parameterize x and y as
we just unit the circling the unit
circle in the XY plane so we can take x
equals cosine T y equals sine T okay so
that will just become the integral over
C well Z times DX z is 0 so we have
nothing plus X is cosine T times dy is
well if Y is scientific dy is cosine T
DT plus y DZ but Z is 0 now the range of
values for T well we're going
counterclockwise around the entire
circle so that will go from 0 to 2 pi
so we'll get integral from 0 to 2 pi of
course sine squared T DT which if you do
the calculation turns out to be just by
now let's instead try to use greens
theorem
- sorry Stokes theorem to do the
calculation so now of course this map
choice would be to just take the flat
unit disk I'm not going to do that that
would be too boring plus I mean we
already kind of checked it because we
already trust greens theorem so instead
let's say you know just to convince you
that yes I can choose really any surface
I want let's say that I'm going to
choose a piece of paraboloid Z equals 1
minus X square minus y squared ok and
well to get our convention straight so
that we should take the normal vector
pointing up for compatibility with our
choice so well we'll have to compute the
flux for s I mean we don't really have
to because we could have chosen the disk
it would be easier but if we want to do
it this way we'll compute the flux of
curl F for our parabola it so how do we
do that well we need to find the curl
and we need to find NDS okay let's start
with the curl curl F let's take the
cross-product between del and F which is
Z X Y ok so if we compute this the I
component will be 1 minus 0 looks like
it's 1 I minus J component is 0 minus 1
plus for K component is 1 minus 0
so in fact the curl of this field is one
one one
now what about NDS well this is a
surface for which we know Z is a
function of x and y so NDS we can write
as so let's call this f of XY then we
can use the formula that says NDS equals
negative F sub X negative F sub y one
dxdy which here gives us 2x 2y one dxdy
ok so now when we want to compute the
flux
we'll have to do double integral over s
of 1 1 1 dot product with 2x 2y one dxdy
will become the double integral of 2x
plus 2y plus 1 DX dy and of course the
region over which were integrating the
range of values for x and y will be the
shadow of our surface so that's just
going to be you know if you look at this
paraboloid from above all you'll see is
the unit disc so it will be a double
integral over the unit disk and we will
do that so one way is to switch to polar
coordinates and do the calculation and
then you will end up with PI the other
way is to try to do it by symmetry
observe when you integrate x over this X
is as negative on the left as it's
positive on the right so the integral of
X will be zero the integral of Y will be
zero also by symmetry then the integral
of 1 DX dy will just be the area of the
student disk which is pi okay
so that was our first example and of
course you know if you're actually free
to choose your favorite surface there's
absolutely no reason why you would
actually choose this paraboloid in this
example I mean it would be much easier
to choose a flat disk okay so tomorrow I
will tell you a few more things about
how curl
in with conservativeness and with the
divergence theorem Stokes all together
and we look at practice exam for B so
please bring the exam with you